welcome to this video playing
International Master Molly chef this is
the real name la silly Molly chef yeah
so many title players that you don't
know okay um yeah I usually go with the
vision a four line some throw it and
Trust it yeah I always believe that C 5
is the way to go if you want to play for
something as white but black is very
solid I have played this line numerous
times myself as black here actually
there is this b5 idea hmm
this is the the the best possible
scenario for this idea with not having
lost tempo it's as you see quite a
complicated quite a complicated line
white gets this very strong piece
thereupon sorry Paul
and what
you think I think I need to take what
check very complicated I play this lines
black also but I always avoided this
specific line because it always seemed a
bit spooky to me
I played Bishop d7 all the time okay he
intends to play Knight c3 maybe I should
you have talked about complicated
positions I can take a fall of course
come on let's get this pawn back and ok
for this I didn't expect at all
so look before he's going rook takes p5
cool very cool move okay so twin
eight-six is probably on and always
there this is the same Forks
yeah I need the rook on c1 badly of
course this is super complicated and
difficult to assess but I'd I rather
fancy white him Knight see who I'm
taking it hangs on e4
the c-pawn just looks very dangerous
yeah 96 is this this right
I don't know very tricky
what you see through me night cforce may
be a real threat IAM guy is playing this
super quickly and it's a really
complicated position I don't I don't
know I simply don't don't don't feel
like I'm understanding what's going on I
think you can take and play Knight C for
now okay Bishop to d8
Queen b5 I'm promoting I didn't plan any
of this if this is working it's pure
luck I simply don't understand what's
going on to be honest maybe I'm ok with
Roxy for Roxy for takes Queen takes
looks very nice
I'm threatening night a seven-year night
a seven and promoting slow-slow in
thinking yeah but I can just promote him
don't piss up yeah this is this is
unfortunate the problem is not the
position to position is excellent but
the time will be very difficult to win
yeah I'm on 30 seconds this would be
quite interesting with an increment to
see if white um you know if he if he
Alaska he doesn't King be - it would be
would be funny
time warning
yeah fifteen seconds this is simply
impossible to to manage
check
yeah come on white resign yeah I played
I played I played it quite quite well I
think just just to sloan check of course
it was it was really lucky that he that
he had this escape
I mean 95 is good okay but yeah
Bishop yeah this is just wrong yeah yeah
it's very very lucky that you had the
smooth here it's just a matter of some
precise and precise moves this is
probably the wrong start this is better
I think that the rook cannot invade it's
it's tricky technically I mean white
shirt should really win but it's it's
still not easy at all it's 40 seconds
against three minutes I mean he played
in especially the first 15 moose just
like instantly and I really never
recovered from that timewise
the problem is that it's not so easy to
even get the e5 pawn and this makes it
difficult
maybe the way to play is f3 and e-form
trying to create a passer in the center
just controlling the pawn with Bishop
and night and trying to get this play
going and tricky but with the time no no
chance really at least not for me maybe
Carew can do it
I cannot thanks for watching